hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the Monday morning podcast
from Monday November 14th 2016 what's
going on I wha my voice is a little
messed up here because you know I've
been traveling traveling traveling I've
been taking my vitamins and they say
over in Europe Oregon OH
vitamins Tomatoes Basel I don't
understand why with ingredients you know
everything else we pretty much pronounce
pronounced the same as [ __ ] Great
Britain but when it comes to spices
everything is different we say oregano
we say basil they say Oregon Oh
Basel whatever the [ __ ] they say tomato
vitamins the only time I really
experienced that the United States as we
say Carnegie in Pittsburgh says Carnegie
bill what are you talking about I don't
[ __ ] know I just got off a goddamn
plane and I watched all the football on
the way out oh my god underrated flying
on football [ __ ] Sunday when there
was two [ __ ] games back to back with
seven [ __ ] lead changes the boring
NFL with their ratings down how great
was Sunday [ __ ] amazing [ __ ]
amazing that that Dallas Pittsburgh game
was incredible and the Pittsburgh
Seattle game was great and I know a lot
of people would think like the thing you
know what the thing I was most upset
about it wasn't the final score it
wasn't the the lack of a call on the
last play with Grunk
it was the Tom Brady picture what the
[ __ ] was that with his hand on his hip
and his how they end up underneath this
jaw what in the [ __ ] was that that's
what happens when you date a supermodel
she's in his goddamn ear just be like
Tom you're just standing there like
everybody else you need to establish
your brand have fun with it be a little
sassy
yes you probably not gonna hear this
from a lot of Patriots fans but I love
the no call at the end of the [ __ ]
game I am forever sticking up for
quarterbacks in the NFL when it comes to
their right to be there to try and
prevent a score you know you know how
this all started old Jim Irsay out there
in Indianapolis couldn't beat the
Patriots defense so he's the one that
created the hole hey the cornerback
can't even look at the receiver past
five [ __ ] yards you know so I love
the no call I thought Grunk did that
thing where he ran right into him he
didn't quite push off but it was one of
those gray area things you usually get a
call on that I feel like 70% of the time
I'll just throw that stat out there you
know I don't read right
I love the no call I wish that they
would do that more but other than that
it was just a great [ __ ] game and I
liked the two cuz Seattle kind of just
played the game rather than doing all
that peacocking around every time they
do something there was one guy that fat
guy the nose tackle for Seattle I was
[ __ ] dying laughing on the plane that
first drive the Patriots had where they
just went right down the field and gave
him the old right there Fred every
[ __ ] play was positive yardage except
for one so we had like six seven plays
in a row where were just crushing it 15
yards 10 yards eight yards 20 yards
right down the field you judged the game
on that first [ __ ] Drive you'd be
like oh my god this is gonna be a
[ __ ] landslide right and then one
play
I think they handed it off to like
LeGarrette Blount and he just runs in to
the offensive line for no gain and that
fat dude stands up any wags a finger
like matumbo over at Belichick in the
Patriots bench hey all those other plays
are gonna work but not that one don't
try that one it's the funniest [ __ ] ever
to me but you know it was an amazing
game and I actually liked the fact that
we lost to him even though they didn't
have Bennett you know they were kind of
hurt and we still lost to him and it was
in our house you know did I just say our
house I'm sorry it was in our Stadium
that didn't bug me because if we meet
him again in the playoffs I'd rather
have lost the regular-season game you
know they would say that [ __ ] like you
know you gotta you always learned more
during a loss
I liked way better losing you know I
think the biggest thing that [ __ ] the
2007 Patriots undefeated regular season
Patriots was the fact that we were
undefeated also Spygate everyone was
just rooting against us I would have
loved it so much more if we went into
the playoffs 14 and 2 or 15 and won just
that you know so everybody what didn't
like didn't have such a chip on their
shoulder the [ __ ] play
I can't even why the [ __ ] I just made
that point oh I know why because I've
seen so many times like it's like you
beat them in the regular season and then
they see you a month or two later and
then they come back and beat you Giants
did that to us the Jets did it to us we
beat him first
no they beat us first then we destroyed
them at home and then a month later they
beat us in the playoffs and it's just
kind of how it goes so I'm alright with
it I'm still not too thrilled with our
defense and can somebody by the way for
the love of [ __ ] God and I don't want
to hear this from a fan I need it from a
football coach can somebody explain to
me the prevent defense I know I've asked
this before but for the love of God can
somebody please explain to me at the
half the Patriots score a touchdown
we're playing with these guys we're
covering them they're not getting any
big plays
we completely abandoned that there's
fifty nine seconds to go in the half we
completely [ __ ] abandon that we start
playing a zone defense I may be playing
zone up until then I don't know whatever
the [ __ ] we were doing was working we
were in a zone defense giving them a 20
yard cushion basically you concede a
field goal okay and we just in 59
seconds these [ __ ] guys seven plays
in 75 yards in 59 [ __ ] seconds in the
last play for the touchdown
watching that wide receiver going from
one zone of the defense to another you
know what he looked like
you ever see when a fan just runs out on
the field and he's just running by
players and they're just looking at him
you know what I mean because that's a
fan security will handle that this
[ __ ] guy because of the prevent
defense was standing by himself like a
yard out from the end zone if not on the
end zone line waving his [ __ ] arms I
mean he might as well have been dressed
in street clothes the level of like non
coverages that is and I understand the
concept behind the prevent defenses is
basically will give will give up the
middle of the field will protect the
sideline and they'll make completions
will tackle them and then they're gonna
somehow eat up this 59 [ __ ] seconds
it never happens I swear to god I think
it's a conspiracy it's a business move
by the NFL it's to increase scoring /
add to the drama if another team is only
up by one [ __ ] score and the other
team goes into a prevent the game is
gonna end with three or four shots at
the end zone or they're gonna kick a
field goal to try and win it it just it
just doesn't [ __ ] work and you know
what's funny so we go into the [ __ ]
prevent and they go right down the field
give us the old right there Fred score a
[ __ ] touchdown all right very
deflating no pun intended for the
Patriots is if we go into the locker
room alright now we got to kick off to
Seattle we kick off to Seattle we play
defense they go three and out it's like
why the [ __ ] didn't we do that before
the half sorry half of this is
emotionally half as I smoked two cigars
two nights in a row which I can't
[ __ ] do I don't understand that on
any [ __ ] level I also don't
understand
when the end of the game Seattle scores
a touchdown they go up by seven points
why wouldn't you just kick an extra
point go up by eight you're acting like
a two-point conversion is it done deal
which isn't which we saw when Seattle
went to go for it and didn't get it
right am i nuts there cuz I kind of
looked away from the screen
they went for two there right and they
didn't get it and then they were only up
by one maybe I'm maybe I'm wrong here I
might be wrong if that's what happened
can somebody explain that move that they
went to go up by two so they'd be up by
a touchdown and a field goal rather than
just going let's go with the [ __ ] 90
something percent thing and kick a
[ __ ] extra point go up by eight and
make the Patriots not only up the score
touchdown but they convert a [ __ ]
two-point conversion if that is in fact
what happened like I said I was on a
plane and you know there was [ __ ] the
[ __ ] look around it and also kind of
like what I like to do is I like to I
like to listen to like ac/dc and [ __ ]
like that when I'm on a plane so I
listen to like the whole flick of the
switch album while I was watching the
game it's actually pretty [ __ ] cool
and also you can actually just sort of
watch the game and not get nearly as
emotional you know because when your
team is losing you start thinking that
the announcers are against your team and
vice versa and all that type of [ __ ] so
I I don't know but I thoroughly enjoyed
that game I'm not one of those [ __ ]
fans that [ __ ] you know his team
loses and then thinks oh we got [ __ ]
and blah blah blah and all that [ __ ]
okay I don't I don't think that it was a
[ __ ] great game and I know you guys
didn't have Bennett and you know and it
was great seeing two of the most [ __ ]
the two biggest cheetahs facing off with
one another one guy who gets all the
press the other guy doesn't do you know
Seattle since like 2010 I think they
recently got passed by the Redskins they
they were the most they had the most
people busted for taking roids you'd
never know that they're in Seattle man
they make coffee nobody gives a [ __ ] you
do that where there's a little bit of
foliage and all of a sudden it's a
[ __ ] national story for [ __ ] year
and a half
as you let it cuts hairs with the air
out of a [ __ ] ball hilarious
it's amazing to me anyway so let's plow
ahead here I I also got to do one of my
favorite charitable events other than
the Patrice O'Neal comedy benefit
tickets are on sale they are on sale I
will tweet out the link again today it's
gonna be at the New York City Center
I believe February 21st I think it's a
Tuesday bill it'd be kind of nice if you
had the actual [ __ ] information
wouldn't it clicking on the camera
camera coupling on the calendar all
right going in its yes February 21st BAM
I got to do the the comics come home
event and this is a really special event
for me because I got to do I did it 20
years ago was the first time I did it
and I think it was at the Orpheum and I
got to meet Cam Neely Chris Nilan was
there I got to meet Denis Leary and I
mean I was literally three-and-a-half
years in my career and it was such an
unbelievable event to be a part of it I
went out and thank God I had a good set
and I remember Leary called me and left
a message I was so bummed I wasn't home
when he called me this is like 20 years
ago so I didn't have a cell phone a
dance machine and you know I act
remember listening to the message like
over and over again and he was like hey
bill it's Dennis I just wanna say thank
you you're really [ __ ] funny
and you [ __ ] kill this is thank you
for for doing it right die [ __ ] off and
I just hung up and I listen to it like
[ __ ] 20 times in a row it was so
[ __ ] cool and then I was also in a
panic like oh [ __ ] I didn't pick up the
phone when he called was that my big
break we would have talked you would
have became friends he would open all
the doors for me you know that those
those over-the-top panic moments that
you have when you're trying to make it
in this business that you think you
every little thing you think you blew it
and you actually what you end up
realizing is this is not one thing it's
a series of things all just building
this [ __ ] snowball that rolls down
the hill before you finally get there so
anyway so I got to do it and it was Jay
Larson it was his first one he did great
Wendy Liebman
leni clock with his [ __ ] lime-green
pants probably gonna forget some people
wanda sykes nicked apollo then me then
Bobby Kelly and that was cool cuz me and
Bobby were closing it out and he's part
of my stand up graduation class and I
remember when we both first got to do
what we would we were in the Jay Larson
spot the first guy out the new guy which
is really hard because nobody knows who
you are enough and you got to go up and
that was just the orpheum and Larson
went up at the [ __ ] TD Banknorth
Garden where the Bruins and Celtics play
and he [ __ ] killed look totally
relaxed and I've never watched him going
like I wasn't that relaxed the first
time I did it and was just in a theater
and you know it was cool I had some
friends there too that was that was
their first comedy show they'd ever been
to and let me let's just say they saw
the gamut of everything that could
possibly happen when you go onstage man
it was a [ __ ] it was a fun night
it was a fun [ __ ] night and you know
and then afterwards everybody hung out
and and I had these cigars that I
brought and I was going I was saying to
the people hey man was there any place
we can smoke these and one of the guys
connected with the Bruins is like okay
there's a room we can go to so we have
going to this like half-assed locker
room
it wasn't the visitor locker room I
don't know what the [ __ ] it wasn't we
went in there and we just let these
things up and just told stories for like
[ __ ] two hours the entire reason I
love smoking cigars and we were in there
so long by the time we got out like they
had broken down the stage and everything
and they were setting it up I think for
a Bruins game I couldn't tell if it was
gonna be Bruins or Celtics it was sort
of midway and just watching the bull
gang or whatever they could get called
just setting it up was so [ __ ] cool
are a little Ober [ __ ] our little car
service back to the hotel had left I
mean like a [ __ ] it we were staying at
the Liberty so we just [ __ ] walked
around the corner and it's [ __ ]
hilarious just walking down the streets
of Boston it [ __ ] 2:00 in the morning
on a Saturday night
and everybody's [ __ ] people hammered
almost a fight here people screaming and
yelling and [ __ ] and it's just like I
it's like god I remember this [ __ ]
[ __ ] the energy of Boston is just
it's so [ __ ] unique it's really just
like it took me a long time to pick up
on it cuz I was just in it you know what
I mean
it's kind of like if your car stink
swimming that commercial will they say
you go nose blind you don't see it I
kind of was like I don't know I couldn't
see how [ __ ] nuts Boston is but I've
said it before Boston is like the sucker
punch like capital of the [ __ ] world
like when you go into a bar
you just it passed a certain hour
there's this anger that settles it in
the bar you just feel it somebody's
gonna [ __ ] something's gonna happen
right you know he said Georgie hear
about OB dude he got [ __ ] suckered in
a bar last night
some kids suckered him he was wearing a
[ __ ] clattering kid I'm not saying
it's all like that but there's justice
that at 2:00 in the morning that vibe
exists number one time walking back from
the Wilbur theater
I can't even more the [ __ ] I was saying
I was walking with two rows I was like
hell I mean I just want to walk you know
it's walk the city a little bit man I
miss in all the memories you know back
in the day going to Emerson College and
commuting and taking the train in to go
to [ __ ] Bruins Celtics Red Sox games
and [ __ ] and I was walking and like
there was two of the angriest [ __ ]
kids I've ever seen in my life it was
like these homeless people laying over
the subway grates and they will [ __ ]
walk up by him and they wouldn't they
would just scream and wake up get a
[ __ ] job like they were like so angry
they would like thirty yards in front of
me and I was continuing to slow down
because I was like if I'm even anywhere
near this guy's orbit he's gonna want to
fight me he was like that level of angry
and of course he's got his girlfriend
who's trying to calm him down oh my god
stop it just just go to the car what are
you doing he's [ __ ] screaming and
he's all [ __ ] angry she's trying to
[ __ ] hold him and he's pulling away
and [ __ ] so of course eventually he
[ __ ] sits down and he's just mean mug
and everybody coming by and everybody
yelled at me and DeRosa and just like
just keep walking just keep [ __ ]
[ __ ] I don't know what it is I don't
know if it's in the water I don't know
what that is but we felt that vibe and
it was funny so we were actually walking
back was me Bobby and a couple of his
buddies and connected with the show
right and we [ __ ] walking back and we
did that thing you know which said don't
walk we were kind of standing in the
street a little bit and these kids come
around the corner in this car the kid
and they jam-packed with kids you know
like everybody [ __ ] piled in his kids
[ __ ] in the backseat he's got this
awful [ __ ] mustache it comes if
you're driving by he's like hey you
standing in this straight as he went by
and I could tell me if Bobby hadn't
lived there in a long time and I just
looked at Bobby and I was just like you
know we were standing in the street and
he's like yeah he was right now back in
the day
that would have been [ __ ] you you
[ __ ] mustachioed whatever and then
they would have pulled over and then you
want to go oh you would [ __ ] go and
everybody's taking their gold chains off
that was the 80s remember the 80s when
you had gold chains right before the
fight everybody's like taking their gold
chain off we'd handed it to your
girlfriend keep your rings on take your
chains off dude yeah so it was always
great to be back there and I didn't get
to I came up there so quickly I didn't
get a chance to go to some of the old
food hunts but my mother made some beef
stew before I left so that was great I
hung around for like a day like an
[ __ ] I hung around till like 6:00 at
night thinking that I didn't looked I
thought the Patriots game was a was an
afternoon game but I got to like I said
I got to watch it on the on the on the
[ __ ] on the plane
on the airplane there so anyways alright
let's get into let's read a little bit
of advertising here I have not watched
the [ __ ] Formula One race yet I know
Lewis Hamilton won and he's closing the
gap so you people who have not watched
[ __ ] Formula One all year I think the
last ones in Abu Dhabi or some [ __ ] or
Dubai I don't know where the [ __ ] it is
right but this one is gonna determine
the [ __ ] window
I think Nico all he's got to do is just
come in third place if he just does that
he's gonna win it and Louis obviously
needs to win the [ __ ] race but it's
kind of cool that it's coming down to
the last one anyways let me get to the
[ __ ] Avatar hm I have to hum my plan
my password or else I won't be able to
talk and [ __ ] there we go all right
here we go
all right Oh on it everybody Joe Rogan's
company on it has a new product it's
called emulsified MCT oil MCT oil is one
of the fastest sources of clean fuel for
the body in the brain it's one of the
best ways to power up your performance
or kickstart a weight management program
there are lots of MCT oil brands out
there but there's none like emulsified
MCT oil from on it available in three
delicious flavors coconut vanilla and
strawberry that's that's my DNA makeup
tell you this every week my coconut at
my vanilla skin and my strawberry pubes
emulsified MCT oil like mixes like a
cream easily in your morning coffee
without the need for a blender no mess
no cleanup you can even mix it with your
favorite into your favorite foods right
now if you go to on it comm / / you can
get on it's emulsified MCT oil for 12%
off that's onn IT comm / bill to get
emulsified MCT oil for 12% off and for
any reason if you don't like it you
could you know give you money back no
questions asked you got nothing to lose
go to Hana comm / / and get on it you
can tell that's Romans company he knows
how short to make the copy some of these
[ __ ] people they write a goddamn
novel oh here's another one
oh give me the loan luke rate everybody
be the end the envy of all your nerdy
friends and get 100 percent off
exclusive crates at luke rate.com / /
and enter my code burr to save $3 off on
any new subscription what is this this
is a trunk full of nerd [ __ ] if you're
into I'm just gonna get to the point
here if you're into movies if you're
into action
heroes or what a superhero's right if
you like taking a bath with some [ __ ]
rubber duckies in there these people got
you covered all right you know you want
to be that nerd at the party that
[ __ ] is got the [ __ ] cool t-shirt
about that obscure movie these are the
guys these are the guys that are gonna
get that nerd chick to come walking up
to you right and later on tonight you'll
both take off each other's hooded
sweatshirts on a quest are you were on a
quest for epic gear housewares and
collectibles loot crate has it loo crate
offers an epic range of pop-culture
items for less than $20 a month if
you're more of a fantastic fanatical
fashionista then try out loo where this
is under no other copy of the world do I
have no [ __ ] idea what they're
talking about monthly wearables and
accessories with cult classics and your
favorite franchises if you want to get
fancy get a bigger box with even bigger
loot with loot crate DX get ready for
them November's enchanting themed
magical o with a wonderful world of
magic here in November loot crate has
cast a powerful ancient spell to deliver
you November's crate featuring
bewitching items from Doctor Strange
fantastic beasts and where to find them
I've never heard of any of that big
trouble little China I love that movie
and so much more
Kurt Russell there when he [ __ ] at
the lipstick on he was biting into that
sandwich was [ __ ] hilarious
do not wait you have until the 19th at 9
p.m. Pacific to subscribe for November's
crate when it's over it's over no more
crates go to loot crate calm slash
burrow and enter my code bird to save $3
off on any new subscription today Jesus
Christ they're all nice and short this
week
this is [ __ ] tremendous can just plow
right through him I think maybe they all
got got together collectively it was
just like we got to help this guy out
he's got to have an aneurysm trying to
read out loud
all right here's another one guys you
know to go to Dollar Shave Club for a
fantastic shave guys
I just bring you all in like we're all
at a slumber party what you probably
don't know is that they have other
amazing products too
the quality is the best on the market
their body wash is great and won't dry
out your skin their pre and post shave
stuff keeps your skin soft and smooth
their stuff will have you looking and
smelling like a million bucks Dollar
Shave club's got stuff for your hair for
your face for your underparts
the OL undercarriage there huh don't
forget the little bit up alright for
anywhere for everywhere to keep you
feeling and looking fresh once you're in
the club you'll see that they've got the
best grooming products out there you got
a hot comb for your pubes and they're
all affordable right now right now it's
your chance to see for yourself why so
many people love Dollar Shave Club if
you're not a member yet and I've never
joined now's the time you'll get your
first month of razors for free just pay
shipping after that it's only a few
bucks join today go to
dollarshaveclub.com / / that's
dollarshaveclub.com / bar alright we got
what do we got two more all right [ __ ]
that I'll read those later alright okay
back to the podcast so anyways yeah so I
didn't get a chance to [ __ ] race was
in Brazil
I got a taped at home I can't wait to
see it because it was raining and that's
one of the coolest things I find about
Formula One racing is that it's like
football they don't give a [ __ ] you know
if it's raining or not they're gonna
keep they're gonna keep racing and I
think that's cool and adds all this
extra elements to the race and you know
it's like with two teams like one team's
favored by 14 and all of a sudden it
starts [ __ ] raining out and every
start slip-sliding around you got
yourself a good game I thought that this
was going to be a landslide one way or
the other like Hillary Clinton I still
can't believe Donald Trump won I still
cannot [ __ ] believe that
a reality show TV star got [ __ ]
elected no Jesus they're two of the
worst [ __ ] candidates ever to [ __ ]
face each other in my humble [ __ ]
opinion boy what the [ __ ] do I know
evidently I know a lot considering a lot
of the [ __ ] emails I got and all the
[ __ ] on Twitter I got a lot of [ __ ] for
my parents on loan
Conan which I gotta be honest with you
guys was not a [ __ ] easy one to do it
was the day after the election everyone
was in shock I think including Trump
supporters because I went back east and
I talked to a couple friends of mine and
they voted for Trump and I was like dude
I can't believe that guy wanted they
were like yeah I can't [ __ ] believe
it either so I don't know maybe this is
like when the Patriots beat the Rams I
have no [ __ ] idea but anyways that
was not an easy an easy spot to be in
you know and I stayed true to who I was
an uninformed jackass who can't [ __ ]
read out loud
who's into conspiracy theory I talked
about Hillary dressing up like a yak and
[ __ ] people under a mountain I talked
about Trump being a dolt
and that whole ridiculous [ __ ] about
building a [ __ ] wall I trashed them
both equally but you know people who
vote for colors right you got a blue tie
you can say nothing wrong you got a red
tie you can't do anything wrong right I
got so much [ __ ] [ __ ] it's so amazing
how people here thinks I actually might
point in all of that was like you know
it'd be kind of cool if we all just stop
yelling at each other all right all
right if you guys if you want to hear my
[ __ ] theories this is my theory okay
I think Trump got in because of eight
years of Obama and the progressive left
and I think they got in because of eight
years of George Bush and I think in Bush
and Cheney and I think they got in
because of eight years of Clinton and I
think Clint got in because of 12 years
of Reagan and Bush it just it just keeps
it goes like way conservative and then
it goes way [ __ ] liberal and then it
goes way conservative you know I mean I
mean think about where America was right
where when Bush and Cheney were there
all right and then six years later or so
during Obama's presidency like Bruce
Jenner transitioned got our own show and
was named woman of the year okay now
that is not something that you would
think could happen in oh seven six years
late a book that's where the [ __ ] is
that and I don't know and what I my
problem with both sides is the way
they've rammed their ideology down your
[ __ ] throat and that if you have a
difference of an opinion you know on the
right it's usually it means you're
against America you don't support the
troops and you're a socialist and on the
Left if you don't agree with them you're
a caveman
you're a [ __ ] sexist you're a racist
you're a homophobe you're any of those
[ __ ] things but both sides equally
try to get you to lose your job and they
try to destroy your ability to earn a
living because of your beliefs and for
the life of me is confusing is the
prevent defenses can somebody please
explain to me how if somebody says
something politically or socially that
you don't agree with spawning a movement
to get them to lose their [ __ ] job
how that makes that person more
supportive of the troops America less of
a socialist whatever the [ __ ] it is you
think they are or how that makes them
less racist less homophobic like I don't
know that doesn't work yelling at people
taking away their jobs you know I mean
it's like way back when the Dixie Chicks
criticized George Bush the [ __ ] right
all of a sudden that there they
pressured radio stations to not play
their music they were they were [ __ ]
running over this CDs with steamrollers
and you know people like to what the
[ __ ] you going a little fun it's like no
they had a right to say that we had a
right to respond it's tit for tat it's
like that's not tit for tat
you know tit-for-tat is they trash
George Bush you defend George Bush and
you trash them trying to systematically
destroy their career and their ability
to make a living is not tit-for-tat
that's like somebody flicked your
[ __ ] ear and then you took out a
[ __ ] knife and cut that trying to cut
that jugular so I'm personally speaking
I think both sides are a really guilty
of that they're really guilty when you
get really far left and you get really
far left right they're really guilty of
just a bully people and they're so
[ __ ] wrapped up in that they're so
goddamn right about everything
that they really become condescending
insufferable [ __ ] and I don't know
so I try to I try to stay in the middle
because I would never tell you who the
[ __ ] to vote for nor did I ever on this
thing unlike what most people saw dude I
got people on [ __ ] Twitter it's
hilarious like they just of all they
think they know me because they watched
me on a talk show and then they think
they know how I voted like the amount of
people that thought I voted for Trump
and then the amount of people that
thought I voted for Hillary all the
Trump people think I voted for [ __ ]
Hillary and all the Trump all the
Hillary people think I voted for Trump I
didn't vote for either one of them I
told you guys right along Bernie Sanders
was my [ __ ] guy that was my [ __ ]
guy and watching him getting boxed out
by the media because they felt Hillary
had more of a chance and they didn't
give a [ __ ] that they were just voting
just more of the same or the same the
only I will commend with the right is
they got there Bernie Sanders in I mean
the guy is a [ __ ] [ __ ] show but at
least you know at least they stuck by
their rebel I wish that they had done
that with I wouldn't love to seen Bernie
against [ __ ] Donald Trump I think
Bernie would I had a better shot I just
think the Clintons had too much [ __ ]
baggage
you know and even as a Clinton supporter
you know that's [ __ ] true how little
did Bill Clinton talk during that whole
[ __ ] time he didn't talk at all this
is a former [ __ ] president who had a
successful presidency I mean even though
he got impeached for sticking a cigar
lying about you know Monica Lewinsky he
didn't talk like Al Gore lost to George
Bush you know he didn't use Bill Clinton
egos I got to get the [ __ ] away from you
dude you're a [ __ ] nightmare you're a
[ __ ] nightmare you're a political
[ __ ] nightmare and the dude's own
wife had to do the exact same [ __ ]
thing I don't know they had a ton of
[ __ ] baggage you know and Hillary
supporters won't [ __ ] look at it
objectively it the same way Trump
supporters won't look at that I mean I
don't know it's just it's a [ __ ] up
time but I will tell you this though at
the time for screaming and yelling at
each other is over I feel and it would
be nice is if those people who aren't
crazy [ __ ] left and crazy right could
kind of maybe break bread a little bit
which I don't think is going to happen
because of eight years of Obama and
eight years of progressive the
progressive left becoming word police
and and and I get social police and an
idea police and all of this stuff
telling you what the [ __ ] you're
supposed to think about everything and
what you're supposed to say and what
word you're supposed to use and I really
think it's overly simplifying saying
that the right voted the way they did
because they want to say homophobic and
racial slurs just turning people into it
that's his back both of them they always
turn each other into like a cartoon like
you ever noticed like whenever like a
Democrat gets in the right totally
overreacting like it's going to be
socialism it's gonna be like communist
Russia there's gonna be terrorists
running down the [ __ ] Street you know
and then whenever anybody in the right
gets it it's always like this is like
Germany in 1935 every [ __ ] time
they say that every [ __ ] time I'm not
saying that one of those times it won't
be [ __ ] true but they say it every
[ __ ] time and they completely freak
the [ __ ] out and I don't know and then
when they get in they ran their
ideologies down the other person's
throat they have zero empathy for
somebody else they have zero empathy for
how people want to raise their kids and
they just both sides they just like
we're 100 percent right and then you're
gonna [ __ ] take this right down the
throat and I don't know each election I
think the pendulum keeps swinging
farther and farther but even if you're
not [ __ ] Democrat you have to be proud
of the last eight [ __ ] years I mean
at least there was no cigars and [ __ ]
there was no they have weapons of mass
destruction oops we can't find any oh
now it's a liberation there was none of
that [ __ ] right who knows who the [ __ ] I
don't know what's gonna happen but uh
you know I'm not comfortable with this
result than anybody else but you
wouldn't know that from all these
[ __ ] things these emails these I'll
read you two I'll try to get through
these next two emails that I got this is
classic like political [ __ ] how people
like they just hear what they want to
hear right so this guy writes me and
this guy is basically I think blaming me
in a roundabout way for Donald Trump
getting in because God knows that's the
kind of power the Monday morning podcast
has you know a couple hundred thousand
downloads I mean that's it dude that's
it I can't believe I don't have Secret
Service security right outside my door
as I do this literally a podcast where I
talk about [ __ ] sports 90% of the
time I talk about conspiracy theory I
say I'm an idiot I can't read out loud
you know this guy for some reason is
choosing to ignore all of this I'm gonna
say because the person he wanted didn't
get in so here we go dear freckles I'm
no rocket scientist
alright immediately going
self-deprecating neither are you okay
agree
I think it's assumed it's safe to assume
the large majority of your listeners
aren't either unlike you I would never
speak for them I don't know I don't know
who they are okay but you know if you
want to assume that to continue on with
your point I'll go along with it most
are like me average middle-class person
has not done one [ __ ] ounce of
research for this but this is this is
this is how we build points this is how
I build a point most of like me average
middle-class folk who laugh like a laugh
twice a week from our favorite comedian
see this this is laying the groundwork I
feel an overhand right coming you have
swayed my opinion on several things over
the years oh Jesus most notably I went
from a patriot hater to someone who
supports them and agrees they are
unfairly scrutinized by the league and
other teams
well isn't that amazing so I guess if I
could sway you on the amount of air that
should be in a football I could sway you
on who you're gonna pick for the leader
of the free world yeah I guess that's
the same you know III can totally see
that point I don't think there's any
sort of giant body of water that you're
leaping over there okay here we go when
I realize when I realized how much your
opinions have influenced me I realized
how much they might influence others
okay here's here's the big failure here
buddy
okay you didn't agree with me on the
Patriots I brought you around you didn't
agree with me with my my political
opinion on Hillary Clinton you didn't
change you know I think that I can bring
your [ __ ] opinion around about using
those say be save [ __ ] you [ __ ] cards in
your everyday [ __ ] life but when I
think it comes down to electing the
leader of the free world I think you go
a little bit beyond the Monday morning
podcast or the Thursday afternoon just
before Friday Monday morning podcasts
where I scream I'm just checking in on
you like a [ __ ] idiot for half a
minute all right so here we here he goes
with this see he's laid see he came out
I'm no rocket scientist
self-deprecating okay then he goes hey
and then he just goes well I'm gonna
assume that this is what your listeners
are without doing any sort of research
and then I'm gonna go oh you swayed me
on this [ __ ] basic [ __ ] horseshit
that means absolutely nothing
therefore you could sway me on something
that means you know Jesus Christ dude
you walk through the mall and there's
somebody's sitting there going hey buddy
can I talk to you for a second this is a
self and look at this you can spray some
spritzer in and blah blah offs and you
buy some little impulse buy thing then
with your theory that guy could also get
you to vote for who the [ __ ] he wants
you to vote for anyways continuing on
when I realized how much your opinion
influenced me I realized how much they
might influence others and how these
influences might have much larger
implications than the NFL call me crazy
but it seems like you're going into
paranoia now after your polls said that
your person was gonna win and now you're
sitting there with your jaw on the
ground and now you're looking for a
scapegoat and Here I am a 48 year old
bald pasty [ __ ] redhead there's an
easy target let's go after him I love it
buddy let's do it
[ __ ] tar and feather me here we go
you've consistently and foolishly bashed
bashed Hillary so much more so much more
than you have Trump hilarious right so
much more than Trump I have an entire
chunk of material on Donald Trump and
Trump was so [ __ ] easy I felt guilty
when I was onstage I did it when I was
on Conan about building the [ __ ] wall
how ridiculous an idea that is how much
money that was going to be I did all of
that I always called him a dope I always
called him a reality TV show star didn't
even remotely respect him as a
businessman I said I didn't believe that
he was a billionaire I said I don't
think that he could get you six grand in
cash if he gave him six or seven weeks I
thought he was completely leveraged out
I made fun of his hair I made fun out we
didn't say anything to anybody he never
said anything it was the most
fascinating thing I've ever seen
he would go like [ __ ] I'm gonna do
this oh I'm gonna do that and some would
be like how you gonna do that and he
would be like oh you'll see
you'll see I was doing a bit my acro and
I want to use that with my wife just
make all these outrageous claims but
what a great husband I'm gonna be and
then when she gives me [ __ ] I well what
are you gonna do to prove yourself all
you'll see you'll see no you need to
tell me well I'm not gonna give away my
strategies then you'll steal him I did
all of that right and then Hillary I
said that she was part of the Bilderberg
Group I talked about the Hillary
foundation and how they [ __ ] been
living off of that [ __ ] they threw a
three million dollar wedding for their
daughter all of that type of [ __ ] all of
her [ __ ] felony charges and
everything which of course all Hillary
supporters are like those were unfounded
they were not proven yet with [ __ ]
Donald Trump six or seven people say
that he sexually assaulted them which I
[ __ ] believe I believe that too that
girl when she went get real which I also
said on the podcast and I was like dude
he definitely did that [ __ ] you didn't
hear all any of this [ __ ] did you sir
you know why because because you got
[ __ ] blue ties stuck in your [ __ ]
ears all right let's go continuing to
blame me all right like evidently has so
much more i trashed hillary the entire
election you have unfairly focused hate
on her and at the end of your tirade you
tack on oh and he's a [ __ ] too you don't
seem to realize the influence you have
on people who listen to you twice a week
every week sir you've done nothing to
prove that I have influence this is this
is all something that you built in your
head when you were hyperventilating that
this [ __ ] monster got into the office
all right and Hillary's a monster too
okay and that right there was my all
when she's a [ __ ] too I didn't like
either one of these people and that was
my message throughout all of this okay
and that's just my [ __ ] opinion
what's I'm allowed to have aren't I
all right you most likely you most
likely influenced at least one voter to
vote for Donald Trump and for that you
should be [ __ ] ashamed dude this is
all [ __ ] conspiracy theory
because you choked you got somebody to
cast one vote for the person that I
didn't vote for you should be [ __ ]
ashamed because I only see the faults of
the guy with the red tie and I don't see
any faults with the person with the blue
blouse all right you are you are so
stupid here we go this is only great to
get some heat somebody to listen to your
opinion usually what you should do
usually should end with the insult say
your point and then you tag on you
[ __ ] [ __ ] because then they'll at
least hear your point but if you start
this if you front-end load alright you
are so stupid that in one sentence you
go from saying how they never talked
about this issue of that issue then
conclude by saying but I haven't watched
any of the debates or kept up on this at
all you [ __ ] idiot yeah exactly
exactly you don't think that Trump
supporters didn't say the same thing
they did buddy because I got that I have
the exact same [ __ ] email from the
other side all right which with my
theory that I'll now use that also has
no research behind it I would say that
you guys all sort of cancel each other
out so whatever influence I had I
influence somebody the other way too so
I am completely exonerated here and if
you look at the popular vote it was
almost right down the [ __ ] middle so
there you go so you he calls me a
[ __ ] idiot all right they never talk
about climate change is something you've
said on Monday the day before the
election you have no clue what you're
talking about well first of all I said
they never do
I didn't say that one or the other so
that was an even-handed one right she
goes clean it Clinton has made it a
major point and supports the Paris
agreement nothing I ever saw she made it
a major point she's commented on it it
goes through the Paris agreement not
that you even know what the [ __ ] that is
you freckled [ __ ]
of course see this guy once again making
assumptions I know what the Paris
agreement is I've seen it on the daily
show I saw when they all talked about it
I saw when they went there and the right
finally said and I actually talked about
this on the podcast
sir when the right went there then they
finally said okay after denying it they
finally said global warming does exist
but it's too late to do anything about
it now all right
I believe I compared that to when Petros
finally admitted that he bet on baseball
and said now can you let me in the Hall
of Fame I distinctly remember saying
that
not that you remember that sir because
you got you bluebonnets stuffed in your
[ __ ] ear right I also actually looked
up weeks ago like when did people first
start talking about climate change as I
was driving down the street and I was
listening and they were saying you know
I would drive down the street that
morning I heard that on NPR they say
scientists say the Great Barrier Reef is
now dead and then they went on to talk
about the Cubs which of course struck me
as funny that the whole rest of the
report should have been about that or
that swirl of trash in the Pacific Ocean
and all that [ __ ] which none of these
guys really talk about they do a little
bit of lip service that's about it but
they're not gonna [ __ ] do anything
about it and even if they try to they
can't because these corporations own
them which is why I like the [ __ ] the
lunatic guys I never vote for the
[ __ ] me people I know whatever
whatever let's just plow ahead so
anyways yeah I actually looked it up and
the first time climate change was
brought up somebody had like a theory
before it was even happening was
projecting that the population kept
growing that it was the theory was that
we would heat up the planet they did
that in the early 1800s I couldn't
believe it and then there was a few more
things about it I can't remember as
weeks ago but like in the late 50s was
the first definitive paper saying since
the 1950s scientists have been telling
people that the pollutions and [ __ ] that
we've been putting in the air or
whatever like I'm not a scientist okay I
am just a regular guy but I read they
have known about it or but had the
attention called to it since the late
1950s okay
so I'm not as I am a [ __ ] but I'm not
as dumb
as you think I am sir and one of the
reasons why I underplay myself it's
because I don't want to be another
[ __ ] jerk-off who's just [ __ ] you
know getting in your [ __ ] ear like
some people in my business okay so
anyways he goes Trump has said
repeatedly that climate change is a hoax
that was created by the Chinese he said
he said it repeatedly I'm gonna look up
the internet see how many times he
repeatedly said that usually when people
say repeatedly it means it's a quote
that somebody said like seven years ago
one time all right and yet you blindly
and ignorantly spew your unfounded
[ __ ] dude you just defined this
podcast why are you acting like this is
Meet the Press he goes I'm not a genius
always back to being humble again I'm
not a genius as you call me a [ __ ]
idiot all right I'm not a political
scientist now he's doing humble pie he's
got his hands up but I took just a few
hours out of my life to research both of
their positions on crucial issues and
get an understanding of them oh yeah I
never did that I didn't do that at all
and I'm not the one speaking to
thousands of people twice a week you
should truly be horrified at the thought
you had anything to do with this [ __ ]
train wreck I love how you dear do you I
do you think that Hillary has any
responsibility for the campaign that she
ran I mean from day one her campaign
could not use an unbelievable asset
which was former President Bill Clinton
because of all of this [ __ ] show that
that guy was both professionally and in
his personal life her husband it was a
former president that was wildly popular
she couldn't even use the guy because of
all the [ __ ] skeletons in his [ __ ]
closet you know and together they both
had skeletons you know it's a very
polarizing candidate that she picked and
I thought in key moments you know where
she really could
come up with something clever to say she
didn't have it look sir be honest with
me what really gets you into office your
policy are playing the saxophone on
[ __ ] Arsenio Hall or not sticking
your head out of a tank and looking like
a [ __ ] dope or getting too excited
and going yeah I mean that's the kind of
[ __ ] that brings people down more so
than anything else and dude that's not
my fault if you want to [ __ ] blame me
for that but that is the truth so you
can actually win an election like you
just saw that [ __ ] dope Trump do
without saying a [ __ ] thing but but
being good at trashing somebody's
[ __ ] shirt which is basically how he
got it promised in a bunch of [ __ ] not
saying what he was gonna do and then you
look at that guy down there he's [ __ ]
clueless and everybody just laughing
Hillary didn't have any of that she had
no [ __ ] swagger she just do never
when she did that hot sauce moment on
that [ __ ] radio show and the host was
going everybody there was
african-american and she goes what's
your favorite you know what you go to
thing what he always carry around with
you and she said hot sauce which
evidently was true okay but immediately
looked like she was pandering and the
guy said are you just trying to pander
sounds to me like you're just trying to
pander to black people and rather than
just saying like nah man I like it I've
been Baba blahblah she goes is it
working well that right though why the
[ __ ] would you say that why would you
say it and when I saw her say that I
immediately I soon I said she's she is
pandering and then people were going
like well actually it's true and then I
looked it up but I go oh it is [ __ ]
true but still this is the thing if I
was really in the [ __ ] hot sauce and
I was [ __ ] running and I was on an
all-black radio station I wouldn't have
brought it up because it would have
looked like pandering and then if I did
bring it up sorry about my voice that's
something go through puberty here even
if I did brought it up then I would have
been honest about it but like no I know
it sounds like I'm pandering but there
are some crossover things I actually
really enjoy it so
you mean you got you got she has to take
some sort of the responsibility that you
know she couldn't beat this [ __ ]
nitwit
all right over 300 of the top economists
not saying that she's not an evil [ __ ] -
over 300 the top economist including
eight Nobel laureates came together to
say I don't know if I said that right
that a trump presidency would mean
turmoil in the American and as a result
the world's economy over 350 of the best
scientists in the world came together to
say his presidency would be a disaster
for the entire planet because of his
dangerous stance on climate change
not to mention Russia literally threw a
party in the parliament building as soon
as Trump was elected that actually I'm
happy
I like when Russia in the United States
are unfriendly [ __ ] terms it would be
nice that we're not going in a direction
to [ __ ] keep pointing missiles at one
another and you know for as much as Al
Gore Al Gore I loved his stance on
climate change he wasn't able to get a
[ __ ] thing done he wasn't able to
stop it he wanted to [ __ ] you got a
few policies in there they just ignore
it and these guys are only in there for
48 years they just wait him out I
remember when Al Gore went to have a car
that got a hundred miles to a gallon I
was excited I was in my 20s I wanted to
buy the car they just kept delaying it
and delaying and delaying it and then
they got on office al didn't beat bush
and then they just scrapped it and it
was [ __ ] over and that's what they do
cuz they don't give a [ __ ] they don't
give a [ __ ] you honestly think Hillary
Clinton would have stopped global
warming if you taught elbows three and
fifty scientists that are all experts
you know what else they've said they
said it's too late it was too late by
the 1980s it was tits Bush or something
in the 90s it's it's been too late it's
[ __ ] it's almost like not even a
[ __ ] issue anymore I mean it is an
issue but the only way to do it was we
would all have to [ __ ] go back to
living like cavemen and a 90 percent of
us would have to die and just kind of
sit there and not do jumping jacks to
add to the [ __ ] heat and hope this
thing could heal itself other than that
I don't know what the [ __ ] you're gonna
do
he's everybody's running around just
having to get a flat-screen TV and every
[ __ ] room
you know I love how it's like the
political candidates are responsible for
it's like we're just as responsible as
anybody else
aren't we I don't know if Jesus Christ
this is like Meet the Press here anyway
so the next time you open that stupid
[ __ ] freckle crusted mouth
this guy's like more enlightened than me
by the way remember your words have
power you are an influential person
whether you want to believe it or not I
don't expect you to read this tirade on
the podcast but I hope you read it and
realize what a fool you've been why cuz
I don't agree with you because you have
all of this admittedly that is none of
this was researched if he just did 45
minutes of research earlier you told me
a couple hours you could see that yes
Hillary made mistakes with the email and
Benghazi yes she made mistakes okay but
nothing she ever did was criminal well
exactly all right well Trump he made
some mistakes with women but none of it
was ever criminal or he would have been
[ __ ] in jail right he would have been
brought up on charges right
the charges what is stuck you can do the
same thing you're gonna completely like
how you don't bring up the [ __ ]
Hillary foundation or any of that type
of [ __ ] either already the other [ __ ]
all that other whatever the [ __ ]
whitewater all of that [ __ ] crap you
don't bring up any of that [ __ ] you
don't bring up the fact that they're
both worth hundreds of millions of
[ __ ] dollars and that's not a red
flag to you these down-to-earth
Democrats to what we're aware men of the
people they're worth a couple hundred
million dollars the presidency pays five
hundred grand a year how do they do it
and don't give me that horse [ __ ] about
they give political speeches [ __ ]
political speeches that they give okay
can you at least agree with me on this
sir that is just that's just those
people washing their bribe money those
are the people that put them in office
and then they go back and they give a
speech and they give them 300 grand two
and a 50 grand to [ __ ] speak their
foreign give me a [ __ ] break all
right
all right so there that's his [ __ ]
thing so he thinks I'm a [ __ ] and I got
Trump to be [ __ ] elected okay now now
here's something exact opposite bill you
really are uneducated on Trump bill you
need to run away from the progressives
this person thinks I'm a progressive
liberal listen to the exact same podcast
sir move the [ __ ] out of California or
whatever a liberal spot you're living in
now this is what I can tell you
immediately it's the last person who
wrote this email is not listening to
this at all it's just it's already
yelling at his [ __ ] windshield about
what a dope this guy's he goes I just
heard your podcast about your the
tearful Democrats yeah he listened to my
podcast anything he thinks that I'm a
progressive liberal and for instance you
had no clue who is going to pay for the
wall dude I've said all along I have no
clue I don't know [ __ ] about football
I watched [ __ ] Patriots yell I can't
name half the [ __ ] people all right
here we go
you have no true this is the funniest
thing I've ever one of the funny things
I've read you have no clue who's gonna
pay for the wall Trump had 100 rallies
where he he asked the audience who's
gonna pay for the wall and everyone
would shout Mexico do you realize sir
that all you were doing was just
repeating what he said was gonna happen
but he never said how we would get
Mexico sir just imagine you didn't like
your next-door neighbor okay and you
were sick of him cutting across your
lawn or whatever the [ __ ] he was doing
you know cutting across the corner your
lawn and making the grass go flat and
you were [ __ ] sick of it now let me
ask you this let's say you've decided to
build a wall and you decided that he was
gonna pay for it how would you go about
doing that exactly now let's move it up
to a [ __ ] country level so we're
gonna build this wall and we're gonna
how will we how is he gonna make Mexico
pay for it and if you tell me it's only
a guess cuz as far as I watched he never
said how
economic sanctions
you're gonna pressure them into [ __ ]
doing it okay anyway so here we go how
is it that those mobs mobs great word
dude are more educated than you who the
[ __ ] is saying that the benefit of the
walls will be jobs who are you listening
to and who said Trump doesn't want
health care he's been really left on
health care saying people with no
insurance should be able to get
treatment and care from way back when he
was running in the primaries seeing that
this guy thinks Trump is left on this
seat this is why this is why sir the
first person that you think I had
influence it's like people just hear the
podcast do you guys already have your
[ __ ] Minds made up and then you
listen to the podcast okay and you it's
like watching a football game and you
listening to Cris Collinsworth I met him
one time when I did inside the NFL Cris
Collinsworth goes everybody thinks I
hate their [ __ ] team and like the
other team better and this will that's
what you guys are doing with this
podcast all right you guys are listen to
this [ __ ] you lean left are you lean
right and when I trash your guy you
think I'm only trashing your your man a
woman and I'm trashing it more than the
other people and then if and when your
person loses you then blame my podcast
all right you guys went out and you
voted for who the [ __ ] you wanted to
vote for and you listened to the
information that you wanted to listen to
and you listen to whatever the [ __ ] you
were receptive to that vibed in your
life which is the exact reason why when
I I was doing this bit on stage talking
about Trump supporters going how can you
support this guy he's got people openly
yelling the n-word at his rallies this
video of that doesn't that bother you
and this is what they would say well you
know I'm not I said this on Conan
they'll be like you know I'm not I know
I'm not into that I'm not in that but
but Hillary then what it is is what
tracks for people is what's going to
affect their [ __ ] life and
unfortunately when it comes to [ __ ]
racism it doesn't track with white
people because it's not a factor in
their life
why people are not victims of racism
despite the fact they say that they are
when they talk about like affirmative
action that that's racist because they
don't understand that the reason why
affirmative action came about was
because racist white people would not
hire people who were not white so they
literally had to come up with the law to
force white people to give other people
a chance and then what people do is they
just look at that moment they don't look
at the history of it they just look
right then and there so I don't know I
think that look I understand that right
now believe me do I understand going to
comedy shows and seeing the way the
[ __ ] crowd is reacting that this is a
very volatile [ __ ] time this guy goes
on to talk about how [ __ ] people
thought Republicans were being dramatic
when they said no to World War three
vote Trump but the Democratic National
the DNC I don't know what the [ __ ] it
stands for force of Russia - why is it a
DNP Democratic National Party make my
life easier force Russia to dump tons of
money into hypersonic nuclear missiles
they have these [ __ ] hypersonic
carriages that can hold 16 nuclear
warheads and think they can penetrate
our missile shields blah blah blah blah
blah and all this type of [ __ ] reputable
scholars were saying that moving toward
we're moving towards World War 3 if you
elect Hillary now they're all changing
there - thanks to President Trump
former host of The Apprentice get on
board with Trump you're annoying voice
should be on our side see he doesn't
think I'm [ __ ] on his side you don't
think I'm on your side both of you have
scholars and scientists that say your
point of view was right because what you
guys do is you go - I'm right calm and
you memorize a bunch of horseshit and
then when your person doesn't win you
then [ __ ] blame a podcast so there
you go I don't know what to tell you
guys I respect both of your opinions I
don't agree on either one of them I
usually don't say who I vote for because
I think it's a private matter but I did
not vote for either one of them
I vote for so I voted for somebody else
Bernie wasn't on the ballot I voted for
somebody else that I thought was the
best candidate not who the [ __ ] I
thought was gonna win and I think that's
a major problem is that people don't
want what's right they want to win
you know so they will go with a
candidate that is a warmonger or a
[ __ ] racist or a corrupt piece of
[ __ ] and they don't give a [ __ ] as long
as they're wearing the right [ __ ]
color type all right and I want that all
right let's see some advertising
everybody but I do have to say this is
let's just say whatever Trump is gonna
do all it's doing for me you know he
appoints this guy and he's got this
[ __ ] past where he allegedly said
something about Jews you know wasn't
proven or whatever but he's got this
[ __ ] background like all that does
for me it just inspires me to become
more of a [ __ ] understanding person
and try to listen to people and as long
as you just take that like that attitude
you know I I don't really don't think a
president should make up your mind on
who you should be afraid of in what we
need to do and what these people are
gonna do to us or what they're not gonna
do to us just because they [ __ ] said
it I don't I don't listen to that what I
like to do is I listen to what the
president says and then I go to the
country and I go to their [ __ ] thing
and I try to find some English story
about what the [ __ ] they're saying about
us and then I try to to figure out what
the middle is all right
I don't I don't give a [ __ ] what color
your [ __ ] tie is all right
so white people if you're nervous okay
liberal White's if you're really a
[ __ ] good liberal white you'll become
even more [ __ ] understanding of
people that aren't white and that are
gonna you know bear the brunt of what
this guy might [ __ ] do I think it's
your responsibility to become even more
understanding you know what I mean and
stop making everything about yourself in
your [ __ ] world because the
mainstream is already about that
all right there you go I'm off my guinea
take that ticket or don't you know it's
up to [ __ ] you all right but I don't
want yeah I don't want to hear your
crying about bumping somebody taking
your [ __ ] I can't stand listen to
white people talking about other taking
the country away from us it's like if
you look at a [ __ ] census you idiot
you know you're fine
okay all the water parks they're made
for you don't give us a second look when
you show up like what's what's his
element doing here they're excited you
there and within two seconds there's
someone in a mascot outfit [ __ ]
hugging you there you go all right
you're gonna be fine all right
driving your four-wheeler on your
property MVM T watches everybody
pronounced movement was founded on the
belief that style shouldn't break the
bank the watchmakers goal is to change
the way consumers think about fashion by
offering high-quality minimalist
products at revolutionary prices with
over 500,000 watches sold to customers
in 160 plus countries around the world
MVM T watches has solidified itself as
the world's fastest growing watch
company movement watches start at just
$95 at a department store you're looking
at a good four to five hundred bucks
movement watches figured out by selling
online they are able to cut out the
middleman in retail markup providing the
best possible price over five hundred
thousand thousand watches sold in over
160 countries get 15% off today with
free shipping and free returns by going
to movement watches comm / / that's M V
M T watches comm / / this watch has a
really cleaned as I always take this
part it's like you already sold them are
you gonna come back around again this
watch has a really clean design
seriously
evidently I've been getting compliments
ever since I put it on I not only am I
not wearing it I actually lost my other
watch it's a nice [ __ ] watch okay I
didn't wear it because I have other
watches you know because I'm in my 40s
and I can afford a nice watch so I
bought that one you know if I was on my
20s I'd [ __ ] buy this one alright and
go to NV TM VMT watches dot-com slash
bar
join the movement but I didn't buy an
overly expensive one I do not understand
buying a super expensive [ __ ] watch I
just don't get it
alright
I don't understand it they all just end
up telling time right I mean this is the
kind of guy drove a Prius for nine years
I I should have a movement watch all
right stamps calm everybody some small
businesses still think an expensive
postage meter is the only way to get
postage without having to go to the post
office but they're wrong
there's stamps calm with stamps calm you
can easily print postage for any letter
or package using just your computer and
printer no extra hardware to buy no
long-term contracts stamps comm can
serve you at least 50% compared to a
meter plus you can do more with stamps
come and you can with the meter like
send package tracking information to
receipts with one click the choice is
clear stamps come offers more features
and a fraction of the cost I've been
using stamp cuts comm for years from my
show
it makes mailing and staying on shipping
really convenient right now sign up for
stamps com use my last name birding at
four week trial plus one hundred and ten
dollar bonus offer including postage and
digital stay at scale don't wait go to
stamps calm before you do anything else
click on the microphone at the top of
the homepage and type in ber that's it
alright cool
alright anyways that's sort of the
podcast here's another thing like you
know I travel a lot so I get to talk to
all of these [ __ ] people out there
and I know somebody that voted for Trump
and was like I think it's exciting I
think it's exciting that he's gonna be
present obviously he's a white dude he's
excited right and this is the same guy
he said Obama's a [ __ ] idiot
alright which you're free to say that do
you think he's a [ __ ] idiot but you
can watch his [ __ ] Donald Trump blah
blah it's just it just I don't know
that's what I learned traveling this
country is just people here what the
[ __ ] they want to hear all right
lingerie let's let's get off politics
I'll give you guys a breather here all
right but uh please guys just stop
[ __ ] yelling at each other
all right it's just stop blaming
everybody and just [ __ ] be human
beings here all right let's be honest
with you Donald Trump and Hillary
Clinton are not out for you or for me
they're out there for themselves and
that's why they're worth hundreds of
billions of dollars make no mistake
right [ __ ] show up in a radio station
with your hot sauce for fun why just
during the campaign and where the [ __ ]
he gonna be the rest of the time you
gonna be the white house buying up
[ __ ] land on aquifers alright eight
Billy nipple slip I recently started
dating this girl and we've been messing
around for a few months now
congratulations she's pretty cool and a
really sweet girl and sex is great with
her all right
trifecta however she's been doing a lot
of lingerie shopping and wants me to go
with her one day so we can shop for her
lingerie together personally I never got
the point of lingerie nor I am a my a
big fan of it
really you just like when they just show
up with like your [ __ ] old basketball
shorts on you're one of those guys as
long as there's a [ __ ] underneath it I
don't give a [ __ ] alright personally I
never got the bucking I didn't see the
point of buying something that was meant
for you to take off almost immediately
after you put it on alright sir this is
the thing about alright see you're
you're you're one of those no foreplay
guys alright if you really want to take
it to the next level dude like you ever
you ever make a meal for somebody and
you set it down and you turn your back
to the stove to set the pan back down
and when you look back they're already
halfway done with it and you're like
what the [ __ ] that I do all that work
for I would let her buy that it makes
her feel sexy right and then you know
gets her all even into them you know the
mood a little bit more telling you do
you're striking me as somebody who never
takes to Downton 6 if you know what I
mean [ __ ] rips the clothes off puts
her on her back [ __ ] rolls off been in
it then it turns on the [ __ ] TV
alright also I'm not that great at
faking my reaction when her or a girls
have broke out their sexy lingerie and
I'm unenthused by it you know what dude
your [ __ ] you really are an [ __ ]
and that could be a good thing you can
you're gonna get what you want in life
but you're gonna miss out on a lot in
life it's even given got me in a great
got me in trouble
a couple times the girls I've been
dating for the most part have been
pretty sexy when it comes to lingerie I
just think it makes things awkward that
is the most overused word on the planet
it's the default emotion of this entire
[ __ ] world now I don't even know what
the word means anymore it's been applied
to everything everything's awkward I
don't know what that means same goes for
things like sexting role-playing vag and
tit picks and anything else that's kind
of puts you on the spot for things
involving sex is it weird that that
stuff does nothing for me no it isn't
but it shouldn't make the other person
feel like an [ __ ]
should I try to do my best do you know
what I preempt I shouldn't called you an
[ __ ] this early because now you're
asking questions alright I apologize I'm
wrong alright I should should I try my
best to continue pretending that my
wiener isn't shriveling up like a suck
when you pull the strings up the strings
out of it oh the other lingerie huge fan
of the podcast I haven't if you haven't
yet please come out I'm not gonna say
where he's from just in case his [ __ ]
girlfriend recognizes this you know dude
you could just kind of go along with it
a little bit like look I think like just
saying you're not into sexting and let
in role-playing and [ __ ] that's like
next-level [ __ ] if you're not into that
that's fine okay but lingerie I think is
a simple thing you could put a happy
face on I mean as much as guys think the
lingeries for them and for the most part
the way women dress like guys are chuh
wads I mean that dresses for themselves
they like to look pretty alright that
makes him feel good so I think delay Nia
can you come in for a second she's
giving me a look here come here now
Jesus she literally walked by stopped
and look at me
alright so this guy this guy is
oh my god it's 1036 I gotta get off my
[ __ ] date so this guy
could you look less enthused yeah you
shot me a look I thought that menu
wanted to come in what are you Henry
Hill I'm just listening what do you want
to say they my wife two times me all
right so this guy he's with this great
girl she's [ __ ] cool she's sexy the
sex is great but she's into wearing sexy
lingerie it does nothing for him she
wants to [ __ ] him to go along on it
and like he thinks it's just stupid
so she puts it on and she [ __ ] pulls
the strings like bah dah dah boo and he
said I'm supposed to sit there and act
like my trick dick is not shriveling up
like a sock what should I do
you don't think he doesn't think
lingerie is sexy he's just stunning he
goes I don't understand the point of
just buying that I'm just gonna take it
off like two seconds later okay it makes
her feel good just go along with it I'm
gonna kill you that's my advice yeah
it's just just go along with it it's now
he said what about like sexting vag and
titty pics he goes I'm not into any of
that or role-playing you are so boring
whoever wrote this in he's really it's
like a job [ __ ] prude and you're so
boring like loosen up a little bit send
a dick pic to your girlfriend no that's
a bad idea yeah you never you know you
never send any of that [ __ ] cuz it
exists forever yeah he'd be the one
person it would come back to haunt him
somehow
so maybe don't do that but just open
your mind a little bit it sounds like
you're in a little sexual box and maybe
you need to no pun intended you need to
break out of this box
but here's explore something different
and you know here's the thing on the
dick pic Nia okay people think okay I'm
gonna send a dick pic to you from my
phone to your phone just think of the
journey that thing takes my dick goes to
outer space
yep goes off a satellite and comes back
down God knows how much [ __ ] is between
that and that I mean how many miles is
that thing just travel yeah and
that that's just gonna go there and then
if you're on like Twitter you know they
say like can we want permission to have
access to your photos and I never say
yes it's like you could have access to
this photo mm-hmm
you know yeah I mean all of a sudden
somebody you know you have to fear
avatars your dick pic yes but if
somebody else's avatars your dick trick
you have to send the dick pic delete the
dick pic and then ask that person to
delete the dick pic - no you never send
pics against Dunson you know what you do
is say where are you
I'll show it to you live no satellite
dick pics yeah but yeah in terms of this
guy I think he should just kind of open
his mind a little bit like I said he
seems a little prudish and it's like
lingerie and all that but I mean if your
girl's into it and you like her and she
likes lingerie like yeah what's the
problem you know just like I said it's
like I don't see any problem how do you
not like lingerie I don't know that's
what I'm saying it's boring as [ __ ] you
saying he wants to show up wearing his
basketball shorts he just like just be
naked that's what I was saying you know
I was comparing it to like you know when
you cook somebody a meals and they eat
it in two seconds you just like dude
what the [ __ ] like you do i do wolf down
food you do huh
but that's not the only thing you is
Christ Jesus Christ Nia why would you
say that no that's disgusting you take a
woman in your in your condition my
condition and your condition speaking
this way that's terrible what if other
people were to hear it I know I think
what would they think all right that's
the podcast here that's it that's it oh
no oh you got me here now well I gotta
go edit my special I got to see how my
especi yeah where I trash both Hillary
and Trump and still get [ __ ] for it yeah
no and then Trump can't win no you can't
win and that's why I never I don't tell
people who to vote for and I but I mean
it is like you know
it's going on so I'm gonna [ __ ] talk
about it because it's fun it's fun to
[ __ ] on them yeah but like I think this
one people are so upset that they that
their person didn't get in that now
they're looking to blame so evidently
the Monday morning podcast has the
ability to sway a presidential election
right well you know you do have a
platform and you have to use it
responsibly I'm gonna start using this
platform I think it's time everybody
buys me a new car
this will be good for America yes it's
completely ridiculous people know who
the [ __ ] they're gonna vote for
yeah it just needs to just need some
time to I don't know I don't know if
anyone's ever gonna be fully okay with
what just happened but Oh Trump
supporters are totally oh they're great
totally okay well good right now yeah
but oh well I'm glad she's [ __ ] gone
but I'm I'm not happy that he's here
there was a there was a lose-lose
situation it's definitely depressing no
matter how you slice it that's [ __ ]
depressing but life goes on it has to
yeah and you know something I don't
think people should just [ __ ] like it
says it doesn't change who you're gonna
be as a person yeah I think if anything
you just do what people are saying you
stay here and you pay attention to
what's going on and you support the
causes that mean a lot to you and just
put all your effort behind that I feel
like that's the way they're like really
make change
should you not move to Canada and no
they don't want us that was no funny
thing to where they all acted like that
they were gonna be so accepting [ __ ]
want us like and like how I feel like
it's really arrogant to just be like I'm
just gonna move to Canada Canada is like
oh okay do I have any say in this like
why do I become the place that you come
to after your country made a horrible I
know but these are these are some of the
great artistic minds on the planet would
be gracing their country with their
songs and there's stand-up comedy they
should be happy they should welcome them
with open arms okay
I like the celebrities were like today
my heart is tonight my heart cries but
tomorrow I fight and I get the little
[ __ ] muscle thing there it's like you
probably go to your personal trainer
first I would think maybe you have your
personal chef make you I put on Twitter
that way like I cried but I felt hopeful
because I did I've never cried after an
election before and I did but I'm done
crying I'm over crying and I'm ready to
move forward you know are you gonna
which is picture somebody crying with
their [ __ ] downtown to ocean views
yeah isn't there like midterm elections
or some come up like a year and a half
or something like that and it's gonna go
the other way you know we'll see what
happens in four years if he gets
reelected or somebody else comes I don't
even know how I didn't understand how
the process works I keep throwing that
out there cuz it and no he said [ __ ]
clean supporter can Bernie run again and
four years do you think no Bernie cannot
win because he's not owned by the same
seven corporations that you need to be
owned by well I'm just throwing out
there but if he comes back and he runs
in four years against Trump I would say
the media will the left media will
[ __ ] take him out again mmm they'll
take but can he win can he really win
that's what they did they [ __ ] him
over they [ __ ] him over and they left
us with this polarizing person and then
she [ __ ] lost and now people are all
going what the [ __ ] happened and they're
blaming podcasts it's my fault now it's
my fault
Trump got in also it's also my flight
have you done this [ __ ] Trump
supporter guy goes like you said they
talked about the cost of the wall how
can you be so ignorant about the cost of
the wall he goes the mobs of people that
show you there must have been is so
[ __ ] dumb I actually think somebody a
Democratic supporters sent inton he said
every time he said it who's gonna pay
for the wall the whole mob would yell
Mexico like how can you be so dumb that
you didn't realize that now that I'm
saying that again I think that that I
think someone was trolling me there I
can't believe someone was that dumb well
but Trump said that he was like we're
gonna build a wall and Mexico is gonna
pay for it I know who would be dumb
enough to think that you can make
another country pay for your [ __ ] we're
gonna build a wall to keep you out and
you're gonna pay for it I was saying
that would be like if your neck if you
didn't like your next-door neighbor and
you built a wall then you sent them a
bill maybe you'd be like make a paper
airplane just throw it back over I have
no idea how he plans on enforcing that I
guess we'll see you know what I do love
is the the first lady has fake tits
I thought they were they were just too
round how would we how would you
possibly know that
I don't know that yeah I don't know
anything I don't know anything I mean
I've said that for [ __ ] years yeah
that's true he has put it out there that
he's got to know he's got the president
has a trophy wife it's [ __ ] hilarious
mmm he's on his third one hey if you
[ __ ] act up don't even think you're
gonna be but you're gonna be sitting
here picking out plates during my second
term lady his wife like doesn't even I
don't know she doesn't even like
register for me I mean yeah she's
beautiful and all that but I I don't
really care I like that she plagiarized
Michelle Obama's speech which i think is
really related to the Millennials the
way they curate you know [ __ ] that they
didn't do onto their Facebook pages and
YouTube pages and [ __ ] make all this
money off of stuff that they didn't
really do oh you mean like sharing of
memes and things sharing of stand-up
specials and music and videos [ __ ] that
they didn't do and they just take it
well I thought that was very Millennial
of our grandpa is that what the young
people do yeah that is what they do
I [ __ ] hate how you just exonerated
all of them from stealing all that [ __ ]
those specials cost me a bunch of
[ __ ] money and everybody just takes
everyone should steal your special and
or downloaded illegally of course I
don't believe that they should do that
yeah you have to understand that you
have a platform on this block yes right
and all of those people that were
already doing it anyways there's now a
bunch of others that are now gonna do it
because you said it was okay hey you
know what's weird is the windscreen is
red
maybe I am a trump supporter oh maybe so
maybe that was a subconscious decision
on your part I like the orange one but
Clio ate it reminded me a [ __ ] ABC's
Wide World of Sports with Jim McKay oh
no you were an elephant you seem like a
jacket as to me nothing oh I didn't get
it oh I didn't get all that those are
the animals right oh Jesus
Democrats are really donkeys yeah why
would they pick that I don't know
there's a reason behind it we just
haven't Wikipedia yeah it didn't googled
it whatever well I'm sure someone will
tell me why pre-empting it hey you
[ __ ] [ __ ] all right that's the
podcast I'm sorry for Donald Trump next
time I will try to I haven't made up my
mind who I want to be president yet the
next time I think I'm already over Trump
and I'll figure it out
yeah I hope so so this doesn't happen
again
you [ __ ] election rigor you don't reg
are you all right that's it I got it I
got a [ __ ] upload this [ __ ] and I
gotta go edit my goddamn specialist it's
gonna be the worst [ __ ] thing ever
all right go [ __ ] yourselves I'll talk
to you on Thursday